thanks everyone for for coming glad to
see such a large crowd most of something
cool go in the auditorium I taught over
we're missing out but anyway I really
appreciate you coming so introduction my
name is Geoff Emerick
I'm at Apache opening LPE committer in
PMC member and their induction said I do
cloud and NLP consulting through a small
company called Mountain fog sorry Jim
today is we're going to talk about
machine translation and air induction to
it what it is the purpose then we'll
look at Sokka which does machine
translation followed by Apache flink and
an example use case and before I start I
like to say that earlier someone
mentioned that these technologies have
reached a point where everybody can use
them and they're available to everyone
so everything in here is open-source you
don't have to be an expert on any of
these tools to use them which i think is
a beautiful thing and I am certainly a
representation of that you don't have to
be an expert because if I can do this
put together a pipeline like this and
anybody certainly can so first we'll
start with statistical machine
translation just to give an introduction
and overview of what it is it's simply
machine translation paradigm where we
take parallel corpora and we make
statistics from it and that helps us
drive the translations and it's our
definition there from Wikipedia so the
parallel corpus there are actually a lot
of datasets out there that we can use
for this type of work
one site called the open parallel corpus
has a bunch of translated text that are
perfect for training these types of
models so there is good data available
sometimes getting the data is the
challenge but here we don't really have
that challenge quite so much there's
various implementations out there today
of statistical machine translation
Apache Joshua licensed under the apache
license of course moses and there's
there's many others those are the two
that came to mind
probably the two there used the most
that you'll run into with statistical
machine translation
the models can be huge 50 to 120 gig
each for Apache Joshua so significant
constraints there on your computing
system just simply destroy the model
when you want to use it and statistical
machine translation is the successor to
the rule-based machine translation which
began which seems like eons ago back in
the probably 50s and 60s where rules
were used to translate text from one
language to another so there's several
different forms of statistical machine
translation one of those is word based
translation and it's simply how to
translate a word the the easiest way
look it up in a dictionary but we run
into problems with that we in different
languages such as the German word up
there that I won't attempt to pronounce
it has many meanings it could mean
building house or tower there multiple
translations and sometimes one is use
more than the other even though the one
used less frequency may be the
translation that we're looking for if we
see that word even though house has 50%
chance of being the right translation we
may actually be looking for Tower this
time alignment so when we have our
parallel corpora we align words in the
source language with the target language
so in this example the building is high
in German in English we can see that
each word is simply aligned with one
other word in the translation and this
is defined by the alignment function and
it Maps the target word in the one
corpora with the word in the other
corporate and for this simple example
it's just a one-to-one alignment the
first word it was the first word second
to second third third depending on the
language is being translated your
laminate function could be a lot
different it could be something else
once a mini translation is when a source
word could translate into multiple
target words an example again this
German sentence this is a high-rise
building the German word again I won't
attempt to pronounce actually means
three things in English high-rise
building so we lose that one-to-one
alignment a phrase based translation the
source input is segmented into phrases
instead of individual words and then
each phrase gets translated into the
target language and phrase based
translation is something that's that's
more commonly used by statistical
machine translation tools so in this
example Berlin is an outstanding art and
cultural centre so we have one phrase
they get to map down to a second phrase
in English so you as we go you can
certainly see how the limitations of
word - one too many to phrase based
translation the alignment function in
the word based models that we saw this
little bit ago the words were treated as
the atomic units and the difference for
phrase based models at the phrases are
now the atomic units and that's what we
translate on and so the advantages
many-to-many translation you can have
non compositional phrases such as rock
and roll if we were to use a word based
model on rock and roll our translation
would be pretty literal rock and roll we
would lose the meaning of the phrase
rock and roll
and up until 2016 this is how Google
Translate worked they use statistical
machine translation models and then
shortly after 2016-2017 the machine
translation world pretty much turned
upside down thanks to the advent of
neural machine translation so if you
ever happen to remember using Google
Translate back in 2016 or earlier and
you thought your translation was
terrible and you went back later and you
did again you got something different
it's because the algorithms change they
got improved a lot
syntax base and hierarchical translation
the syntax based translation is based on
partial parse trees instead of the
actual words and phrases so in this
you're breaking the sentence down into
its sentence structure into its parse
trees and for hierarchical phrase based
translation is a combination of phrase
based in syntax based translation and
Apache Joshua and Moses I believe both
use hierarchical phrase based
translations so they're able to use the
phrase base plus the syntax based and
and that pretty much I think represents
the state of the art of statistical
machine translation today challenges of
statistical machine translation even
just in our simple examples that we saw
you can probably guess that when
languages have different word order it's
it's not going to do real well when we
saw that the words lined up one-to-one
or even the phrases it was good but if
you have a language going from one
language to a different language or the
languages the words come in different
order for whatever rules there might be
in the language statistical machine
translation is known to have trouble and
like most things in the NLP domain it
generally does best when the text that
you're translating is in the same domain
as the training text so if you know if
you're if you trained on books in
different languages and then you took
your model to some other type of text
newspaper articles or something
different it's probably not going to do
as well because you're outside that
domain and the writing style also has an
impact so if you stay in the same domain
with the same writing style then you can
get decent results of statistical
machine translation and lastly and maybe
most importantly specific problems are
hard to find and fix and that sounds
simple but it's it's very true and it's
very troublesome it's it's a hard
problem
you you have your parallel corpora and
you have everything matched up and
you're trained and your algorithm learns
one translation to another one maybe
simply because it happens more and then
when you run it on your data you see
that it's not giving the output that you
want and you you're kind of at a loss as
to why does the translation think this
is right
and and finding that problem and fixing
it and retraining requires a whole lot
of effort to fix and sometimes when you
find and fix it
you break something else so now neural
machine translation so same concept
going from one language to another
except now we're applying neural
networks to it because in today's age
I'm pretty sure we take every problem
and throw neural networks at it today so
might as well just do the same thing
here right we still require parallel
corpus so we still have to have text in
the source language and the target
language different from statistical
machine translation is that neural
machine translation happens on a per
probability distribution one word at a
time so we're not looking at phrases
we're not looking at rock and roll we're
not looking at anything like that we are
only concerned with what is the next
word that we're going to predict for our
translation and surprisingly the work in
neural machine translation actually
dates back to the 1990s kind of like
other stuff did with neural networks
it's actually quite old but recent
advancements have have made it
practicable practical and usable now and
unlike statistical machine translation
neural machine translation uses vector
representations
also called embeddings for the words
we'll take a look at that a little bit
so power about neural networks the these
neural machine translations use what's
called an encoder decoder architecture
and if you're familiar with
neural networks and I'm sure you've
probably seen or heard a lot of this
before but it's simply that you have one
network that's called the encoder shown
in green and then you have the decoder
network shown in blue the encoder
network takes the text converts it to
the vector representation also called
the embedding then that embedding gets
passed to the decoder and the decoder
tries to translate it to the target
language so over on there's a quote over
there from Google's paper on the neural
machine translation says our model
follows the common sequence the sequence
learning framework with attention it has
three components an encoder network a
decoder Network and an intention Network
the attention Network also shown in this
picture here allows the decoder to look
at other words in these input as it goes
through and translates it so it gives
the decoder a little bit of context as
to what the next word might be when
there's a paper called attention is all
you need that's a real good reference on
adding attention to neural machine
translation but when that was done the
performance of neural machine
translation improved greatly and the
link at the bottom and the Google link
over there are both really good sources
for more information on their own
machine translation also why I move from
statistical machine translation to
neural machine translation so you could
probably tell that well we haven't seen
yet but results were simply too good to
be ignored there was too much potential
to come to too many ways that we can
improve illness and other reasons were
smaller model sizes with Apache Joshua
we suffered or still suffer with model
sizes anywhere up to 120 gig if you go
an Apache Joshua's webpage and download
the language packs it's 100 gig hundred
twenty gig per language so we don't have
that now the nmt generally has a simpler
training process it's easier to train
your models using their
machine translation less code if you
compare the actual source code for
neural machine translation and
statistical machine translation there's
actually less code for neural machine
translation I should caveat that a
little bit because the neural machine
translation frameworks are built upon
neural network frameworks like
tensorflow
so some of that code is not really part
of the neural machine translation
toolkit but actually the neural network
toolkit underneath it
and lastly potential so when we
translate text from one language to
another how do we know how good it was
how do we score that translation we have
to have some sort of metric as a
threshold to be able to tell how good we
did there's two metrics that are
probably the most common the first one
blue bilingual evaluations under study
is probably more common of the two and
it simply compares what the machine
translated with how a human would
translate it and it's a very inexpensive
metric it's easy to run
sokka and I believe others will help you
generate it when you get done when you
evaluate your model so it's it's easy to
calculate and it does this by looking at
word overlap between the translation and
what the human would translate how much
word overlap is there between the two
and it produces a value between zero and
one where higher is better and typically
you'll see the value expressed actually
between 1 and 100 and I think common for
neural net their own machine translation
you'll see values in the 40s or so and
that's a pretty big jump from where it
used to be just a few years ago the
other one the translation error rate is
a metric that describes how much change
a human would have to make to a
translation to get the original meaning
so let's say that we had a sentence and
we went on google translator somewhere
and we translated that sentence
how much work then what a human have to
do to modify that translation to match
the original meaning of the input text
and it also gives you a value between
zero and one but in this case lower is
better because we don't want to do any
post editing work to our translation so
with those in mind this is a chart from
WMT neural machine translation
competition and it in blue you can see
the statistical machine translation
submissions and in orange you see the
neural machine translation and so 2013
14 15
you had statistical starting at 15 you
had neural and then you can see that
neural networks quickly passed
statistical and then in 2017 there were
no statistical all work had changed over
to neural machine translation and
coincidentally in 2016 was also at the
time that Google changed their
translation over to use neural machine
translation so it's pretty interesting
results that that shows the the
potential of neural networks and I
believe the the y-axis is a blue scores
so you can see getting up to 30 and I if
I remember correctly I think there have
been some state of the art that may have
gotten up into 4 in the 40 range so a
quick tool comparison just comparing two
implementations one of statistical
machine translation and want a neuro
machine translation just for me it helps
to just kind of see these things side by
side Apache Joshua and sockeye so it
packs with Joshua reasonable quality
translation I'm not backing that by
metrics I'm just from a real world usage
you know you can you can qualify it as
as reasonable quality widths are kinda
narrow machine translation it's
definitely improved so it's much more
higher quality the implementation of
Joshua's job in C++ Sakai Python 3
in C++ and model size is is fascinating
a Sakai model usually around 200 nagger
so somewhere in that range compared to
to joshua 60 to 120 gig how the
difference in implementation in which i
touched them a little bit before Sakai
400 lines of code well one difference is
the last row there
Apache Joshua generally less expensive
compared to Sakai generally more
expensive and what I mean by that is the
the requirements to make a model and
train it Sakai the neural networks you
know I tried it at home on on my desktop
computer which is not too shabby but you
know it's not it's not anything fancy
and it ran for days and days and days
and days and I moved it up into Amazon
on one of the GPU instances and through
a bunch of GPUs at it and it still took
a while to complete pachi Joshua you can
get by with with less so training Sokka
is a model is is definitely a very
expensive hardware intensive procedure
so representing texts of vectors I heard
some talks this morning talking about
word embedding so you probably heard
those two as the the network is trained
each word in the vocabulary gets
assigned to a random vector and it gets
that value gets updated as the network
is trained so the network is learning
the the word vectors is embeddings as we
go
some nmt frameworks open and empty does
I think Sakai does as well you can use
your own pre-trained vectors from word
Tyvek or glove or fast text and this can
definitely improve performance if you
have those
a common problem with statistical
machine translation is how do we handle
words that are outside our vocabulary if
we translate a source text if we trained
on the source text and then we try to
translate a word we've never seen before
what do we do how do we handle that one
recent solution to this that has been
proposed is to use byte parent coding
and by parent coding in case you're not
familiar actually is a data compression
algorithm that dates back to 1994 so
it's not novel to the world it's just
novel to its use in neuro machine
translation and what it does it allows
machine translation to work on the sub
word units instead of whole words and so
what would allows us to effectively do
is we're simulating an open vocabulary
now that we're treating instead of
treating whole words we're now looking
at pieces of words and this the code
link there is is the code in the paper
that presented this approach also an
example of byte para encoding we have
the phrase nonsense phrase positional
Edition contextual we can replace the
TAS with exes the ALS with wires and
EXO's with Z's and so we can we can
build this and we can see the sub word
units as they call it in the words and
trained on those instead of the words
positional additional contextual it's
it's all based on the intuition that
various word classes are translatable
via smaller units than words and in my
experience and I think others as well
using vbe during your neural machine
translation will greatly help your
performance it will help you get rid of
the unknown words that could could
result during the translation and this
block is the code from that paper that
implements
the bite Perry encoding so it's a
relatively simple thing to implement and
do so now let's take a closer look at
Sokka so Sokka is an open source neural
machine translation toolkit
it's developed by Amazon it's based on
the mix net deep learning framework
written in Python
license are in the Apache License it's
up on github so everyone's welcome to
try it out and give it a give it a run
there's excellent tutorials on the
readme and other places that will walk
you through getting data training it
using it so you can get some hands-on
experience with it I provide
state-of-the-art encoder decoder
architectures those three architectures
are described in intimate detail in the
paper referenced here so it's it's a
it's a great read fascinating read if
you want to get down into the nuts and
bolts of how it works
so when Sokka we can use our bite pair
encoding to help with our training and
it's a pretty simple command
there's your command learn joint bpe and
vocab you give it your corpus and some
parameters and it generates it for you
so it's not complex or anything tricky
and the the link there is step by step
on how to use or build bpe vocabulary
before training you don't have to use
bite pair encoding if you're doing
translation or building a model you can
train sock out without it but it
certainly helps your performance to do
so so now we want to train and use a
soccer model these are the steps that's
there you can install it and then you
can just execute soccer train and give
it the parameters your source corpus
your target your bpe files that were
made from the last one and your hyper
parameters for it for the network
and lastly your output is the filename
of your model which I very uncreate
typically or copied probably from their
name model so they don't get confused
and then to use it you can just execute
socket out translate give it your model
and you can pipe text to it so you can
pipe the the German sentence there and
it will give you back the green house
and so this exact example is what's
listed on the blog there that you can
walk through and try it for yourself
Apache Frank is a distributed framework
for processing streams of data it it is
a java application but it it's really
nice and it allows you to process either
events in batch or streaming events and
for this use case we're going to use it
for streaming so real-time events which
we'll see will be from Twitter come into
the flink application and their process
thereby being translated by sock out and
before we continue I did want to mention
the patchy beam I did not use beam here
for this work but it's definitely
something to keep in mind in the future
if you're not familiar with it you can
write streaming jobs in one of several
languages they currently support Python
Java and go to run on many streaming
platforms like local which is what my
example use case here does on flink
spark dataflow one caveat is that the
Python implementation doesn't yet
support blink it does support Google
dataflow so you can write your job and
Python and execute on Google dataflow if
you want but it's a really cool project
where you can pick your language and
then pick your streaming runtime to run
it on
so example use case we have an incoming
stream of tweets that we want to
translate to another language the tweets
are received by an Apache flink
application the application processes
them sends them to Sokka where they are
translated and the translated text is
simply written to the console so the
tweets come into flink
there's a patchy thrift layer that
facilitates communication between flink
and Sokka it gets a translation back and
writes it to the console just mentioned
one showed again that thrift is what's
facilitating that communication between
flink and Sakai and it's using some code
from github there that implements the
thrift connector for Sakai the NLP
operations because running in Apache
flink which is Java are provided by open
NLP we're using two operations here the
first one is sentence detection to
extract the individual sentences from a
tweet and you're probably thinking
sentences in a tweet how many tweets
have sentences of course it it's it's
not the best but you can you can imagine
if you're using it from some other
source you might have actual sentences
and instead of tweets so in most cases
it returns one sentence and that's
simply the tweet itself the second one
is language detection throughout tweets
by language so I currently only have
this set up to translate German tree
tweets to English but we could certainly
add other languages in there as well and
that language detection lets us route
the tweets to the appropriate thrift
endpoint for translation so if we had a
German to English and in Spanish to
English from French to English Sakai
models running we can do language
detection to send them to the
appropriate model for translation and I
apologize for the Java code my point is
not to get into the
but I just wanted to show you how simple
the code is and this is the Apache flink
code here that does the language
detection so it's not anything
complicated and it's it's not anything
out of the ordinary
this simply loads the language detection
model and then predict predicts the
language given the text of the tweet
itself and again from the flink
application we have two streams the top
one is a stream to read from Twitter the
second one is a stream that does the
sentence detection model and then does
the translate at the bottom so again the
point is just to show to help illustrate
that the the flink application is not a
not big that there's not a lot to it and
it's up on github you can take a look as
well so from examples from the Twitter
stream I put these in here just in case
I didn't have internet access or
something during the presentation but
when I did it and ran it you can see the
German translate the German tweet at the
top followed by the English translation
below it and I will switch to it and I
hope you can see this so this is the the
console output of the streaming job I
started this prior to the presentation
excuse me
so as you can see the German tweets
coming in and below it you can see the
translations in English and this is
running in real-time apologize if
there's something that's you know not
the best but there but so you can you
get an idea of how it works and it's
very simple to run this on your own
computer clone the code from github
and start the the 3ft RPC start the
flink job and you can just watch it go
just like that that literally was all
there is to it so everything I've talked
about in here was open source software I
just want to reiterate that and and
briefly mentioning in the applications
that were used Apache flink for
consuming the real-time tweets Apache
open NLP for language detection and
sentence detection on those tweets
Apache thrift for facilitating the
communication between Sokka and flink I
did not use Apache Joshua but we talked
about it a lot so I wanted to mention it
again
statistical machine translation toolkit
Apache mix net deep learning framework
upon which Sakai is built and Sakai
itself seeing what's the sequence no
machine translation framework demo I
just showed you and credits and links so
the first one Sakai tutorial is a way to
go if you want to make your own model
and play with it
flank the the last three are what you
need if you want to build and run this
on your own computer the streaming in
EMT code is the flink application sub
word in Mt
is the code from the paper for
generating the byte pair encoding and
the sub word units and lastly the Apache
thrift for Sakai connector credits like
to give a shout out to the open NLP team
and the Sakai team for helping put this
together and special thanks to Sunil and
for the initial implementation of the
streaming app and Kelvin for the Sakai
thrift implementation and thank you very
much
if anybody has any questions I'll be
happy sir yes the translation is Winnick
when it comes in it's I mean I'm sure
there's a little bit delight but it's
pretty instantaneous yeah yes
GPU to run nun to run that's actually
running on a t too small amazon instance
so so very small there too if you want
to train it you need everything but to
run you don't need much to run it yeah
yes
I don't but earlier we had some metrics
back here so there's two big metrics
blue and ter translation error rate the
top one just measures you know compares
how well it did to what a human would
make and the second would this compares
how much editing a person would have to
make to fix it
yes
yes yes so they are both recurrent
neural networks the the encoder takes
the words and produces the vector the
representations and then the decoder
just takes that vector representations
and tries to reproduce the text in a
different language so it's it's pretty
much mirror operation from the source
text to the to the embeddings to the
target text yes the the attention
network just allows the decoder to to
have more context about the word that it
is trying to translate at that time so
it allows the the decoder to look at
that word and the surrounding words
around it to help with the translation
correct yes I think so
anything else well thank you I really
appreciate
[Applause]